[Musique]
emmanuel bretons bonjour bonjour merci
d'être sur le plateau de tv soixante dix
huit pour ce vip qui vous est
entièrement consacré vous êtes ici parce
que vous êtes artiste peintre est ce que
vous êtes et vous les noirs et parce que
vous avez une énorme actualité voilà
donc on va parler de tout ça déjà la
qualité en deux mots c'est une
exposition à saint germain en laye je
crois jusqu'au 15 juillet jusqu'au tient
à l'analyse à l'ailier du cadre d'or
c'est morgane et une jane encadreuse qui
se lancent et qui bossent hyper bien et
je me vois pas beau c'est quelqu'un
d'autre
déjà la l2 secrète vous faites une
équipe hyper créé j'expose vos apps
qu'elle a elle-même encadré exactement
dans l'atelier se fait exploser les
dessins il ya un bout de un beau dessin
déchiré je me déciderai cela qu'il faut
les lui donne des ailes à la géniale
série collaboration alors intéressant
d'aller voir donc ça c'est dit ensuite
un week end à peu chargée ça va être le
5 6 juillet temps des 5 600 1 ou cagnac
sa part du vendredi à trois jours donc
le vendredi 16 juillet à la cour des
senteurs à versailles qu'un endroit
juste magique est organisé un dîner en
blanc
exactement et vous fait l'animation oui
une peinture avec christophe rault
juillet la guitare et clovis raclée à la
percu et la peinture sur 10 mètres de
long on sait pas ce qu'on va faire je
vais peindre en blanc ah oui blanc sur
blanc blanc sur noir s'est gratté dans
le blanc et les traders vont apparaître
et aux musiques donc vous avez des amis
musiciens qui improvisait en même temps
avec voile organique et amis avant et un
autre par la collaboration qui est
devenus amis
mais c'est vrai qu'en fait tu es obligé
de bien entendre avec les gens quand tu
fais un truc comme ça parce que tu sais
pas où tu vas donc tu as vraiment besoin
de faire confiance et on se soutient les
uns les autres comme ça et ses principes
de la pro même cattrall parce que si on
écoute pas l'autre on peut pas lui
répondre et ses pattes rien quoi vous
n'êtes pas j'imagine ce soir
voilà donc soro dîner en blanc s'inscrit
et soyez plus de place on peut tout de
même passé vous voir travailler en dire
achetons c'est possible il avait ouvert
des senteurs et derniers événements donc
ce qui a lieu le samedi et le dimanche 6
et 7 juillet car et à la farine c'est au
tour du marché à versailles c'est un
lieu c'est une exposition une galerie
voilà ils vous avaient organisé une
exposition alors vous êtes un petit peu
nombreux racontez moi on est 13e au
début on était quatre on était parti sur
une exposition où ça a commencé à coller
s'était pas coller dans le sens où on
n'arrive pas à bouger ça n'allait pas et
donc avec les quatre on s'est dit qu'on
se trouve un truc où on respire on est
bien et en 24 heures j'ai appelé la
mairie les a
jean marie gilbert delphine tout ça est
manal de crépy ils les ont trouvés le
carré la farine pour le lendemain
pascal blain ouais parce qu'on a
l'habitude de travailler ensemble et
puis c'est vrai qu'à la fin d'année il
ya plus beaucoup d'actual prémolaires et
ça fait plaisir de d'avoir un retour de
confiance avec la mairie ils vous ont
laissé carte blanche mais cartes d'un
jeu complet de leur avait dit je
m'occupe du truc
j'aurais que les artistes que j'appelais
il était hyper motivés il se trouve que
la plupart on avait déjà bossé ensemble
sur d'autres projets c'est qui ceux qui
sont ces artistes et des gens que vous
connaissiez que vous appréciez qui sont
à versailles qui sont ailleurs pas
coincer des gens de versailles
et c'est des gens on se croise soient
différentes expos de chacun bosse comme
ça soit chez des amis en commun mais ya
souvent un lien dollar parce que il y en
à soi qui n'exposent pas comparé exposé
beaucoup et dont le quand je vois le
travail je comprends pas parce que c'est
déjà hyper mature et un vrai trail
d'avancé et là cela il faut qu'ils en
voient pas ce qu'ils méritent vraiment
d'aller plus c'est ça ouais il suffit
juste de et puis et puis d'autres avec
qui j'ai toujours plaisir à travailler
pareil c'est avec la confiance et puis
aussi le la relation percée des gens ils
sont au point dans leur travail donc
dans leur tête aussi ce décor je
comprends il ya de la money et de la
cohérence ce fait être exactement les
corps il ya aussi joseph dadoun parmi
ses jambes pas parce que nous lui avions
réservé un vie
de consacrer un vip ya deux ans quand il
avait investi la chapellerie chaud et
joseph dadoun donc exposé aussi avec
vous parmi les treize artistes
on a partagé un atelier pendant deux ans
avec joseph n'a en fait on travaille pas
du tout de la même façon ses regrets et
là je les appelais ça faisait un moment
qu'on s'était pas vus et puis il ya un
boucher pas il est toujours quatre coins
du monde à exposer elle a dit oui j'ai
deux trois peintures là ça pourrait
aller c'est super très bonne initiative
on y va en france c'est super tout s'est
bien goupillé quoi parfaitement et puis
voyez joseph comme il est fabien c'est à
dire c'est la joie quoi oui le garder
qu'un truc justement hop
méfiance allez on y va ces êtres qui
vous motive aussi la joie j'ai
l'impression ouais j'en ai besoin parce
que j'ai besoin d'eux juste un peu comme
la peinture elle commence et je sais pas
où elle va j'ai vraiment besoin de me
sentir presque un peu en sécurité d'un
point de vue technique donc avec les
gens avec qui je bosse pour après
libérer complètement tiers de noirs
voilà pour laisser dépasser journée
vraiment valable éventuellement c'est ça
alors voir venir justement avoue
emmanuel burdeau maintenant qu'on a un
peu denses et le tableau de toutes ces
futures d'actualité donc ça va durer
deux jours le car est la farine mais y
aura d'autres sections pas ce que vous
appelez frelons v session 1 donc mais
tout ça sous-entend cessons de etc
donc ça c'est dit alors racontez moi un
peu votre vie déjà vous vous êtes vous
êtes autodidacte vous avez fait des
études d'art vous avez décidé à quel âge
que la peinture c'était vous mako témoin
en quelques mots ma mère faisait de la
peinture déjà mais elle a eu deux
enfants
ma soeur et moi et là et je me sois
j'étais allé d'une expo elle à
tourrettes sur loup dans le château de
tourrettes sur loup il était très fier
d'elle de son travail
sûrement parce que ça me parlait c'est
un langage aussi donc c'est ma mère
selon gas la fenêtre et est déjà
familier
et quand je lui ai dit c'est super j'ai
raté prochaine expo et balles arrêtées
et pourquoi tu arrêtes maman bas parce
que ses deux enfants et je me suis dit
bon je n'aurais pas d'enfants mais je
ferai ça un peu c'est pas c'était comme
tout et la fusée las le truc et puis tu
as l'autre truc qui continue c'est
peut-être ça un peu la famille aussi
ouais donc volé moi j'ai pris le relais
voilà donc ils sont plus à l'est dans la
communication entreprise tout ça et puis
moi vraiment c'est la tête c'est la
peinture brut c'est à dire maintenant
c'est bien toi que tu mets les mains
dedans tu balances et ses lettres qui
s'exprime donc là on n'est pas du tout
dans une forme de séduction
on est vraiment dans un besoin de
respiration ce besoin peut être un peu
violent au départ parce qu'il ya des
trucs à nettoyer mais petit à petit il
ya une maîtrise de la technique qui
arrivent et où justement parce que la
vie ou la fréquence houleux
l'énergie d'avis qu'elle n'est pas
violente lls et c'est en rondeur sais
c'est que c'est comme ça que je le
perçois mais après c'est aussi une
question de foi je pense
pour moi c'est comme ça qu'on c'est
comme ça que le monde la création allait
juste entre la nuit et la naissance
s'est pas forcément pendant la vie c'est
alors qu'entre la nuit la naissance il
ya tout qui est ou qui se passe et après
pendant la vie c'est juste la continuité
est un être vivant il n'a de sens dans
la vie que de s'harmoniser avec tout ce
qu'il dépasse d'avant d'après pendant et
le langage de l'art pour moi c'est ça
hein dehors de toute forme de
marchandises ou marchandisation c'est ça
bousquet je vous coupe le goaler brut ce
soit côté brut et surtout ce qui est
quand même moi je trouve génial c'est
que vous vous en vivez de votre peinture
vous ne faites que ça vous avez démarré
avec en essayant d'allier des petits
boulots alimentaires et vous me
racontiez que le matin vous arriviez un
peu crevé un peu plein de tâches de
peinture c'était surtout les taches de
peinture qui est aidé dans la deuxième
j'ai crevé à la limite on est tous un
peu crevé quand on fait un job déjà
qu'il nous plaît pas spécialement mal à
vous aviez de boulot et un moment vous
ai dit que finalement je vois c'est
suffisamment pour pouvoir gagner le même
argent en ne faisant que ça au début ce
soit là et quelques fois où vous a enfin
certaines personnes ont pu vous
connaître aussi je dis ça pour les
versaillais parce que vous avez démarré
avec des des choses que ton des passages
piétons la nuit que vous avez orné de
vos oeuvres
un peu à la cocteau on peut dire ça
cocteau fait penser à 7 $
mais en fait cocteau mathis du stade
moreau plein d'artistes c'est comme
c'est un adn du trait du dessin c'est un
langage donc c'est très très
civilisationnel alors que là tu
reconnais les étrusques les
civilisations grecque antique que tu
m'aimes des bas-reliefs de mésopotamie
c'est un même c'est un même adn du
langage de l'inconscient collectif
je pense ça parce qu'ils ont tous été
passionné par sa il revient au cif et
mais c'est une passion qui se vissent et
alors c'est pas une passion un tel
intellectuel vous aviez étudier non
c'est parce que c'est quelque chose tu
te tout d'un coup à peindre des
musiciens je vais apprendre des gens qui
dansent tu t'en des inflexions de la
fécondité des ronds des voiles à des à
coups de désenchantement des planètes
des mots sévères comme ça c'est dans
l'inconscient collectif de chacun enfin
au moins des artistes peintres peut-être
vous êtes vous sortez ça c'est en
réflexion c'est sa soeur est de plus en
plus aussi parce qu'il ya une
sédentarisation qui déjà je sais pas
problématique mais en tout cas c'est un
fait et donc il ya l'esprit qui a besoin
il dit à lettres un régisseur le truc il
faut parce que sinon après ça crée des
problèmes psychologiques aussi des
noeuds de tout et vous votre récent de
de réagir à ça c'est de vous exprimer en
peinture
exactement et je pense aussi c'est aussi
parce que le système scolaire
j'ai pas trouvé de
de langage de justement de respiration
etc c'est étrange
certes est en tout cas j'ai dit existe
un bien sûr mais pour moi ça n'a pas
fonctionné et donc j'avais une
frustration d'autant plus grande parce
que je sentais un langage très profond
je n'avais aucune utilité dans la gaieté
à l'intérieur qui est fait à l'intérieur
je savais qu'il engage la les voix
comptent proposer et avait aucune parole
qui pouvait les dessus c'était j'étais
pas capable de me passionner pour une un
des tunnels donc jusqu'au aussi fabriqué
mon métier par la peinture d'accord et
un côté les jobs que j'avais ça ça a été
une école sociale
sur une ouverture au monde exactement le
rappelait même au marché du travail
commence à vraiment comment ça
fonctionne ça vous aide pour vendre vos
toiles ce qui vous avez un agent pas
j'en ai un depuis un vrai jésus d animer
les gens sont vraiment des gens ça c'est
un problème de langue des étoiles aussi
ouais bah là c'est parce que j'y arrive
mais qu' il ya des projets où je sais
que ça me dépasse un peu
tant mieux et j'ai besoin de quelqu'un
qui viennent voilà quelqu'un dans
l'attenté c'est un designer en fauteuil
qui préfèrent grandi manuel c'est génial
c'est parfait l'expérience alors on se
retrouve le 6 et 7 juillet car et à la
farine avec 12 autres artistes et vous
vous créerez alors être moment la
pareille en direct sur sur quoi vous
aller peindre
pour l'instant on est sur du pvc blanc
oui ça peut changer lay 2 mètres 50 sur
sur 1 m 20
alec et sur 1 mètre 50 avec de la
peinture noire je pense que je vais
travailler ici ceux que je vais ses
avants à vous restez sur le noir et
blanc comme au dîner en blanc
en fait il sera recto verso pour moi je
tournerai autour les gens pourront
tourner autour donc je sais pas trop les
deux faces comment elles vont être cet
appel à un planning c'est ça et d'autres
artistes isabelle guillet va faire une
sculpture pendant les deux jours aussi
carole va faire des dessins clairs
ferrer aussi de plusieurs artistes vont
vous faire vivre de mon art in the
artist espace population il se passe
quelque chose contre est créé avec la
musique
et voilà mes collections et d'y aller il
va se passer tout le temps quelque chose
alors n'y a pas d'heure particulière
pour les créations humeur ne sera plus
dense c'est là qu'elle midi tranquille
le dimanche à la fin du marché
d'accord mais sinon tout le temps il y
aura une performance tout le temps
pendant les deux jours d'accord jours
déjà et est de 12 à 20 heures toujours
des musiciens de 12 à 20 heures génial
bravo d'avoir organisé ça on a hâte de
voir vos oeuvres vos oeuvres en création
et vous avez déjà fait créer et merci
manu merci doit très bien plaisir on
reparle du reste à l'occasion avec
plaisir à voir
[Musique]